drew sedora the housewives band-aid has
been ripped
off your first episode is out in the
world how are you feeling about
officially
being a real housewife of atlanta it's a
ouch moment
i was like nerve wrecking i was really
excited you know
it's one thing to film it and then watch
it back it's just like
i didn't know that was even said oh my
god like to see it all
it was just i'm still breathing though
i'm alive we're all good we're here
and so let the journey play out there
were
some shady moments on both sides you got
your digs in
i'm just saying somebody need to tell
her though
people got their digs in at you seeing
drew i'm just kind of underwhelmed
anything that surprised you that was
said in that first episode
you know i felt something with kenya
like i didn't know because it wasn't in
my face but i did feel the energy just
i couldn't figure it out so after
watching last night oh it explains
a lot you know what i mean of why the
relationship ended up or ends up where
it is and um even with latoya
like they never said it to me so i just
was like wow
that's really shocking a pet on my head
that's what we're talking about kenya we
know kenya but latoya this is also our
introduction to her
and it was like you're coming in guns
blazing okay
shots fired she has a pen on her head
okay but i just need some wine
i mean i was shocked with her behavior i
was just like wow
okay not even just towards me but you
know to our gracious host cynthia
she walked in and she was just very
comfortable
you know and i was just taken aback by
her energy but um it explained a lot for
me so now i
i am fully woke well let's rewind a
little bit
i was in the game but now i'm calling
all the plays why was now the time to
join real housewives because i
from what i understand this had crossed
your desk a couple times
it actually did three times so the first
time was back in 2015 i was pregnant
with my now five-year-old makai
and before i was gonna take the trip to
atlanta my water broke
at 28 weeks and that was really serious
and i was
immediately put on bed rest hospitalized
thankfully he was delivered healthy
but he was born premature so that just
wasn't the right time it was like
obviously not you know family first that
was really a scary experience
but then they called back and i actually
got a chance to hang out with eva marcel
and cynthia at her wine cellar opening
and then they came back for season 13 i
was like okay
like god what are you trying to tell me
obviously this is
it and it's meant to be and i just felt
like with
everything that i've gone through 2020
has been a rough year i'm sure for
everybody so
it was just like i have a lot to share
and i would never have the opportunity
to share it you know just doing a film
or tv you would never see that i'm
dealing with so much in my life
so i just felt like it was the right
time you are sharing a lot that first
episode we learned
so much was there any moment where you
were like oh no
baby we shared too much ralph we
shouldn't have said so much
yeah how about day one
[Laughter]
day one i was like this was not
at all how i thought it was gonna go it
just
happened you know because he left right
before we started filming he left
i did not know where he was and it
unfolded
did you leave georgia absolutely where
did you go if you don't feel like you
need to tell me where you went
then we can dead in it right there
dead in what it unraveled literally with
the cameras and i definitely didn't plan
that and nor
did i want to i wish i could have taken
it back in that moment i was super
embarrassed which is why
you saw me walk off because i was like
this is too much i'm done but
all in all as you'll see we're dealing
with our marriage now and we're in
counseling and i'm super grateful for
that
you've worked through these issues
you've gotten to a better place it
sounds like
we are definitely in progress okay
counseling
is ongoing and i think that was the
major thing is we've gone to counseling
in the past
but we didn't stick to it you know we
got to constantly deal with the issues
in the present you know until we really
have a solid foundation and that's what
we're doing so
was this the first time he had run away
like this where he was gone
and in communicative for three days or
is this a pattern for your husband
so this was the first time he was gone
for dates there was an incident in the
past where he did
leave and he got on a plane to go back
to los angeles
but he did not take off he walked off
the plane he
sometimes just needs to get away and
that's who i married and
now he goes to the gym but yeah he had
never left for that many days so that
was new
and that's why it was so heartbreaking
to me well it's red flag territory is it
not
it was red flag territory for me which
is why i was like we
gotta address this to make it to seven
years which
ultimately we love each other we're
committed to our marriage
you have a camera in the house that
watches us i have cameras everywhere
okay
so were you watching us when you were
gone no that's a lie you're gonna lie to
me
you're lying to me did you ever get
answers
on whether he was hang on you or not
yeah you know
you gotta watch um because i am still
getting answers i gotta answer a new
answer last night
from a family member so i was like thank
you you know
it is an evolution and we're on what's
called a journey
you know reality shows have a
history of making or breaking
relationships so was that ever a thought
that like
oh we're gonna lay it all out there this
could backfire on us
it's kind of like when you've tried all
different things like we tried the
arguing we tried so we'll let's
separate you know we've tried all those
different things and kind of when you
get to this point you're like
what else do we have to lose you know
like this is something we haven't tried
which is
putting it out there being able to see
ourselves in a real true light
if anybody watching can relate to that
and we can help someone along their
journey too
i think that's a blessing all right from
your personal story to the group story
let's walk through some of these ladies
that you're getting to know
i feel like i know most of these answers
but i'm going to ask
anyway who is the most the most
welcoming cast member
oh my god for sure cynthia and um
portia for sure those are my ride or
dies
least welcoming cass well we all watched
in america most definitely latoya
um from jump and i think kenya you know
she just didn't take to me
you know the way that i would have
expected i don't think it was warranted
um i just think it was pretty nasty
so it is what it is you know you can't
get along with everybody and i'm
learning that
so as much as it would have been awesome
because i really did
look up to her you know when i was a
little girl and
it was unfortunate okay i'm taking the
look up as little girl as a little uh
slight shade there kenya did i talked to
her
about a week ago and she said drew is
thirsty
drew is parched
and she's got a beverage so she's all
good
i take care of myself i'm a big girl and
um you know it's a shot and i take it
for what it is
you know sometimes negativity comes in
different forms
and right now it's it's just coming from
a fluffy face
and what did you make of her dog pound
comment oh
cynthia where do you get all of these
strays from honey i mean what do you do
just
visit the local pound it was a nice
little kitten i mean honestly listen
i'll take that on the chin
because it's coveted i was doing the
best i could
i was laying down my own wig and i felt
very good about that
i wasn't allowing people in our home my
mom was living with me and i was like
okay
i mean you know could've it could have
been a little shiny it could have been
but she was a cute little kitten
she was a cute little kitten and and i
felt good about it when i walked out the
door
and like i said i think all girls can
relate to the struggle
of kovid and us trying to keep our looks
together which castmate surprised you
the most
over the course of filming season 13. i
would say
portia i mean portia i just i'm so
inspired by her
by her black lives matter movement and i
think just
the woman that she's become she's super
strong she's so much fun you know she's
through everything that she's even going
through in her personal world
i just feel like she's amazing amazing
mother
she's an amazing woman and the movement
that she's created and really taking our
culture
and taking the movement forward and
continuing that fight putting herself on
the front line
i can't commend her enough and i'm just
amazed at who she is
inside and out truly on the flip side of
that anyone who really disappointed you
this season i am definitely just
disappointed by kenya i think
even just as the woman as an
african-american woman
in this industry and the fight that we
see that's going on in our culture
i just think it was really disappointing
to see her take just such a stance
toward another african-american woman
and um i think it's it's sad and as
we're wives
dealing with our marriage and mothers to
continue to be that example to our
daughters i just feel like we could have
done so much better and i'm
i'm truly disheartened that she took
that route especially when when you lay
it all out there like you just said you
have a lot more common ground than you
do differences so
to for her to poke at them is uh is
surprising
yeah because i'm transparent and i'll be
the first one to say i'm not perfect
you know i am definitely not perfect and
that's even why i
am here because i'm here on a journey
like everyone else is trying to figure
it out
and so for her to actually come for me
in that way it was hurtful
you have an instantly quotable moment in
the trailer don't forget i'm from
chicago [ __ ]
what drives you to say that well i am
from chicago and i'm super proud of my
city like i love chicago we have great
food great people
in that moment though i was
triggered in a way that just sent me
there you know
it's like where i come from it's a line
that you don't cross
i am super chill i pretty much can get
along with a lot of people i i just like
to have fun you know
and there's a line and that's that
respect line and when it's crossed
then i can't then it's all bets are off
you know and at that moment that's what
happened it was like look
you don't know me you think that you
know me but let me let you know
i'm from chicago and we don't play those
games so who crossed the line is it the
person we've mentioned
about a half dozen times so far
[Laughter]
you'll have to watch and see but you
know you pretty much can figure it out
from the first episode
we have to get into stripper gates
i'm hearing sex noises coming from a
bedroom
it wasn't a sex party
who said that she's making disparaging
comments about me
and you involving a strip wow i'm
overdosed
what do fans need to know about this
moment we'll see later down the line
i had such an amazing time that was my
first bachelorette party i ever attended
so i was just like
this is incredible like it was so much
fun and i was
shocked to hear like all the aftermath
because i always thought like what
happens at a girl's bachelorette party
stays at a
girl's bachelorette party and that just
wasn't the case
i don't know what happened i don't know
what they're talking about i was in my
bed sleep
so i'mma be sitting there eating my
popcorn
right along with y'all watching it
because i have no idea you're gonna be
getting the answers as we get the
answers
absolutely because i don't i don't
believe it to be true
at all and so i'm confused i didn't know
cameras were rolling but
like at the end of the night i felt like
we all had a good time and i went to
sleep and i thought everybody else did
too
you know things stay at a bachelorette
party unless they're broadcast on
national television for everyone pick up
work so
looking ahead there's a lot of season
left to watch what are you most excited
for the viewers to get to experience
i'm excited you know for just everyone
to meet my family i'm excited for
everyone to meet my
little three angels my mama
who y'all gotta taste pastor jeanette is
already a star
[Laughter]
esther jeanette oh that passage internet
pastor jeanette is a whole lot of
character i'm happy
about you know everyone getting a chance
to meet my mommy so
anything you're dreading re-watching or
the audience experiencing
a lot but i mean i i feel good about it
because i'm being just super
open and super raw and it's a journey
and everyone's going to witness that
so as scary as it is i am you know truly
here for it from everything you've said
it seems like it was a net positive
there were some wins there are some
losses but you come out at the end
happy you did it uh you know what a good
time exactly it's life and that's what
i'm learning beyond this journey it
really is life it's like you take the
good the bad the ugly
all of it and in the end of the day as
long as i can grow from it
um i'm happy about that for a second i
thought you were gonna break into the
facts of life theme song
take the good you take the bad you take
them both and there you have the backs
of life
which was gonna send me because both
kenya and cynthia told me you remind
them of when kim fields was on the show
but you're willing to get in the mix a
bit more and you know what shout out to
kim fields
she is an icon a legend a talent to be
reckoned with
and she has opened up doors even for
myself coming up in that so
again disheartening that you're an
actress wanting to be back on the screen
and you tear down someone
that has been super important to our
industry into our art
you are awful the award goes to kim
tooty fields
for best in jamaica i love the kim
fields
i will take it i actually grew up you
know watching her
my mom and ken field's mom were friends
so how about that
how about that take that to wrap things
up here if you had to boil down
your debut season of the real housewives
of atlanta into one word
what is your word for season 13
roller damn coaster roller
coaster it has been every day it's it's
been an experience
breathtaking at times stomach butterfly
all all that you would think it's been
all of that